اجت فكره فلسفه اللون الازرق هي بتحمل كل
هاي المعاني مثابره الابداع الافق الواسع
يعني السماء لا ينتهي فبلشنا بانه اه فعلا
ممكن يكون ازرق
سميناه الحجر الازرق الفكره انه انا بدي
اعمل مشروع اذا المشروع يكون بضم كتير من
الشغلات ويكون بيئي مجتمعي يوفر لي مصدر
دخل
فاجت فكره انه ممكن ادرس وقع نفايات في
فلسطين اتعرف عليه اشوف شو المشاكل اللي
بواجهها فعند البحث وجدت وجدت انه واقع
نفايات جدا سيء في فلسطين للاسف ما بيتم
بعد التدوير النفايات في فلسطين فانا حكيت
انه هون في فرصه ممكن انا استغلها يعني
المشكله هاي هي فرصه لحتى احنا نبني اكثر
الفكره انه
اعيد تدوير النفايات الصلبيه اللي ما
بتتحلل مع مرور الزمن فاذا فكره الزجاج
الزجاج هو ماده صلبه ما بتتحلل
فجبتها وقعدت افكر بايش ممكن استخدمها بعد
محاولات بما يقرص المؤشر من المحاولات
والتجارب طلعت بفكره الحجر الصناعي
الداخلي وبعد هيك بلشت الفكره بعشرين واحد
وعشرين بلشنا من حجر الصناعي الداخلي
وحاليا نحن بننتج الكثير من قطع الديكور
اللي باستخدام في الديكور الداخلي يعني
كمناظر جماليه
[موسيقى]
احنا منساعد او نعمل تعاون مع المشاريع
الصغيره للنساء مثلا عنا في صبايا
بيشتغلوا بموضوع الشمع صبايا بيشتغل
بموضوع التوزيعات او موضوع الزريعه زراعه
القوابر فاحنا بنوفر هاي القواوير باسعار
مناسبه لهذه المشاريع وهم كمان بيستخدموها
في مشاريعهم او احنا بيكون عنا طلبيات
لشموع او لا احنا مش تخصصنا انه نزرع عم
نعمل كل هاي احنا بنتعاون معهم بزرعوا لنا
واحنا بنسوق هاي المنتجات نشارك فيها
بمعارض مع جمعيات مع بزرات او سواء كان
نعرضها عنا على صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
الخاص
[موسيقى]
ه صغيره متوسع على يتوسع على كثير من
الاماكن يعني الفكره هي قابله انه تتطبق
في في اماكن مختلفه
انه نوسع المبادرات المجتمعيه لحسن نشتغل
عليها ونوسع نطاق تسويقنا للمشاري